the biggest story in the country right
before the virginia gubernatorial
election was the battle between parents
and school boards and you'll recall
that the doj
basically acceded to a request from the
national school boards union the
national scoreboards association to
start looking into
people who are upset with school boards
as potential domestic terrorists there's
a letter sent from the nsba to the fbi
and the doj asking them to treat people
who are criticizing school boards
overtly and voraciously to treat to
treat them as though they were domestic
terrorists they tried to invoke the
patriot act and you'll remember that
merrick garland was brought before a
senate committee and he was asked about
surveilling parents and checking into
parents and was the doj going after
parents for the great crime of being
angry at their school boards and here's
what merrick garland had to say
what does the national security division
have to do with parents at school boards
this is not again about parents at
school boards it's about threats of
violence section 223
that statute covers
the use of not just telephones but
telecommunications devices
to annoy to annoy someone
so are you going to sick your u.s
attorneys in the fbi on a parent's group
if they post on facebook
something that annoys a school board
member judge answer that is no
so they're not going to do that right
they're definitely not going to track
people's communications they're not
going to spend their time doing this
okay so now according to the wall street
journal breaking story fbi tracks
threats against teachers school board
members
quote the federal bureau of
investigation has set up a process to
track threats against school board
members and teachers moving to implement
a justice department directed that some
law enforcement officials and republican
lawmakers say could improperly target
parents protesting local education
policies the heads of the fbi criminal
and council terrorism divisions
instructed agents in an october 20th
memo to flag all assessments and
investigations into potential
potentially criminal threats and
harassment and intimidation of educators
with a threat tag which officials said
would allow them to evaluate the scope
of the problem
the internal email asks fbi agents to
consider the motivation behind any
criminal threat and whether it
potentially violates federal law
agents should tag such threats
edge officials you better track them
according to the memo which was reviewed
by the wall street journal
okay and the story continues the purpose
of the threat tag is to help scope this
threat on a national level and provide
an opportunity for comprehensive
analysis of the threat picture for
effective engagement with law
enforcement partners at all levels says
the email signed by the fbi's assistant
director for counterterrorism
an fbi agent provided a copy of the
internal email to several republican
lawmakers citing concerns it could open
the door for the bureau to collect
information on parents voicing their
opposition to local school policies
during meetings
the fbi said tuesday in a statement the
fbi has never been in the business of
investigating parents who speak out or
policing speech at school board meetings
and we are not going to start now we are
fully committed to preserving and
protecting first amendment rights
including freedom of speech the new
procedures were prompted by an october
fourth memo from a.g merrick garland
ordering the fbi to help local leaders
address threats to school personnel a
move he has said was aimed at stopping
violence against teachers and school
staff over politically charged issues
now the question of course is why that's
not a local law enforcement issue if
somebody issues a threat against me i
report it to local law enforcement that
we get threats all the time they report
it to local law enforcement
it is not an fbi issue why is the fbi
investigating this the reason the fbi is
doing it is at the behest of the nsba
the fbi in its statement described a
threat tag as a tool to compile
statistics and track information about a
range of issues
the creation of a threat tag in no way
changes the long-standing requirements
for opening an investigation nor does it
represent a shift in how the fbi
prioritizes threats said the statement
garland said during a correct
congressional hearing last month that
while he didn't have a full accounting
of such threats nationwide complaints
from school board officials and news
reports show that the problem is
becoming more prevalent
now again the question becomes he was
asked specifically do you know of a
serious uptick in death threat and he
said no i really don't have evidence of
that we just have kind of news reports
why this merits a federal investigation
and a publicly stated federal
investigation is sort of beyond me
the other problem of course is that your
trust in the fbi has been somewhat
shaken over the past few years given the
fact that the fbi initiated an entire
investigation against carter page based
on the clinton campaign just making up
crap about donald trump and then handing
it over to the fbi and that eventually
would be mainstreamed into the steele
dossier which would be mainstreamed into
the media which would be mainlined into
the mueller report
so yeah my trust in institutional law
enforcement to look into quote-unquote
threats by parents
i am i'm skeptical to say the least
some republicans say the justice
department is thrusting the fbi into
what is usually considered a local issue
they say the tactics are an effort to
silence parents who speak out at school
board meetings about topics such as mask
mandates and how race is addressed in
schools
the ag issued his directive shortly
after the nsba asked president biden in
a letter for federal help in dealing
with threats by people opposed to face
mask mandates for stemming covered 19
and to the teaching of critical race
theory the association has since
apologized for the letter which
suggested that the doj treat attacks and
threats against public school officials
as hate crimes or domestic terrorism a
spokesman for the group didn't
immediately respond to requests for
comment on tuesday
at a house intelligence subcommittee
hearing earlier this month several
republican lawmakers pressed
the fbi on the new directive does the
fbi consider parents domestic terrorists
and representative elise stefanik of new
york switch the fbi representative said
no quoting as long as individuals are
not committing federal violations force
or violence and promoting an ideology
they would not be
okay but that october 20th email
suggests a broad-based
concern
by the fbi with parental feedback aimed
at school boards
according to javed ali who teaches the
university of michigan the fbi will have
to tread very carefully they can't open
investigations into people showing up
and protesting when someone crosses the
line of direct threats of violence
whether in the physical domain or
virtually that is crime but the question
is why is the fbi involved in this at
all and why are they publicly announcing
that they are involved in this other
than to attempt to quash people
suggesting
criticism of public school officials and
here's the thing
you're public school officials
and and it seems to be true across a
wide variety of states public school
officials are very often directly at
odds with parents
they're they are enabling and
effectuating policy that is rooted in
radical ideas about gender about race in
the united states and parents have every
right to be pissed off every parents
have every right to radically
transparent to oversight of these school
boards when you delegate your kids to
the public schools you're not saying
that the public schools get to educate
your kid in whatever the public schools
you fit you are saying that your
educational priorities ought to be put
into what the schools teach your kids
hey that you are delegating okay you
you're reserving the right to educate
your kids
but you are delegating that right to the
schools with the understanding that they
are then not going to indoctrinate your
children in a bunch of radical garbage
and yet that is precisely what our
public schools are doing across the
nation i'll get to some of those stories
in a second because this scares the
living hell out of me and it should
scare the living hell out of you
because the public schools are still
churning out the majority of students in
this country
they're affecting how families operate
they're affecting how families are able
to teach their values to their children
it's why we need school vouchers across
this country as fast as humanly possible
every parent not just the wealthy should
have the ability to take their kids out
of the local public school and put their
kid into a school that reflects their
values
it is imperative at this point
and there has to be a radical shift in
how these school boards operate and if
the school boards don't want people
taking money out of the public schools
and putting their kids in private
schools maybe they ought to start
reflecting the priorities of the
parental communities that they actually
are supposed to serve here are some of
the stories that are creating alarm
among parents and they should be
creating alarm among parents and they
are from all over the country
so this one from brittany bernstein over
at national review reporting on the
situation in west hartford connecticut
quote elementary school students in west
hartford connecticut public schools are
being forced to undergo social emotional
learning through an equity lens as
district officials have reportedly told
parents they may not opt out of the
curriculum which aims to teach students
a set of social justice standards
parents from the district district
contacted the non-profit parents
defending education to share concerns
over material being used to teach
elementary students about group
identities including transgender content
being taught to kindergarten students
one parent raised a red flag about when
aiden became a brother a book being
taught to fourth grade students that the
parent described as full-on gender
theory which is teaching students that
the sex you're assigned at birth is
wrong
the description of the book reads when
aiden was born everyone thought he was a
girl his parents gave him a pretty name
his room looked like a girl's room he
wore clothes that other girls liked
wearing after he realized he was a trans
boy aiden and his family
fixed the parts of his life that didn't
fit anymore and he settled happily into
his new life
when aidan's parents announced they're
having a second child aiden wants to do
everything he can to make things right
for his new sibling from the beginning
including choosing the best name and
picking out the right decor and clothes
the book asks what making things right
actually means
another fourth grade mentor text is a
book about pronouns called they she he
me free to be
the lessons are supposed to teach
students in kindergarten about social
justice standards including identity
diversity justice and action
the identity standard includes texts
that teach students about transgender
people and the use of preferred pronouns
including the inclusive singular they
a mentor text for a kindergartner
student is introducing teddy which tells
a story about a character and his teddy
thomas thomas says i've always known
that i'm a girl teddy not a boy teddy i
wish my name was tilly not thomas
another text for the kindergarten age
group is let's talk about race
meanwhile a first grade text includes
jacob's new dress a story about a girl a
story about a boy who wants to wear a
dress to school and are you a boy or are
you a girl a book about a character who
prefers not to tell other children
whether they are a boy or a girl
third graders are reading a similar book
called ten thousand dresses about a book
about a boy named bailey who dreams of
magical dresses but people in his life
tell him he should not be thinking about
dresses because he's a boy but later he
begins making dresses with a new friend
fifth graders read i am jazz and it
feels good to be yourself which says
quote some people are boys some people
are girls some people are both neither
or somewhere in between
in an emailed appearance the district's
director of equity advancement dr regina
haskins explains that the schools have
quote redoubled district-wide efforts to
attend to the social and emotional needs
of children and adults
it explains that the aforementioned
social justice standards come from the
framework of the collaborative for
academic social and emotional learning
haskins writes that the group
acknowledges that while sel alone will
not solve long-standing and deep-seated
inequities in the education system it
can help schools promote understanding
examine biases reflect on and address
the impact of racism close opportunity
gaps and create a more inclusive school
community so we are now indoctrinating
kindergartners
in connecticut in the idea
that boys and girls are malleable
categories and that a boy can be a girl
and a girl can be a boy because there is
nothing that is healthier for a child
than confusing them about their gender
let me just explain something about
children i have three there are seven
five and one if anybody approached my
kids and started telling them about how
they might be a member of the opposite
sex
that person would be out of my house so
fast would make your head swim this is
predatory behavior upon children
confusing children about their sex is
disgusting it's disgusting gender
dysphoria is an actual condition
it is not a cute little thing that ought
to be promulgated to tens of millions of
school children across the united states
gender dysphoria is an actual mental
disorder according to the dsm-5
pretending that mental disorder is
is a
somehow referendum on the notion that
there are binary sexes in life
or that your child should be taught
about the supposed malleability of sex
contra all science and evidence is a way
for you to prey on children it's a way
for you to screw up kids who are not
suffering from gender dysphoria
the belief that in service to kids who
have gender dysphoria you have to screw
up an entire generation of children by
telling them
that inborn biological characteristics
are of no consequence whatsoever
is it's vile and parents should be
standing up to it at every single level
it is not merely connecticut public
schools that are now teaching this sort
of crap according to the new york post
a new hampshire teenager is suing his
school district after he was allegedly
suspended from athletics for saying
there are only two genders
the exeter high school freshman said in
the suit he was hit with a one game
football suspension in september
stemming from a text conversation he had
with another student off school grounds
the lawsuit was filed november 4 through
an attorney with a christian
organization cornerstone action with the
claim that he stated a catholic-based
belief that there are only male and
female genders
by the way that's not a catholic-based
belief that's reality
okay because either gender is a complete
spectrum in which there are an infinite
number of genders or there is a male
gender and a female gender and you can
sometimes have characteristics of one or
the other while being a biological male
so it can be an effeminate male or you
can be a very masculine female but that
does not change the fact that male and
female are categories that exist
the kids lawsuit also claims exeter's
policy on non-binary gender identity and
pronouns infringes on his first
amendment rights the policy says
students have a right to be addressed a
right to be addressed by a name and
pronoun of their choosing related to
their gender identities and also says
those who don't recognize others gender
identities or pronouns are violating the
policy
the student
was suspended for denying that people
can belong to a gender other than that
of male or female
the student it goes on will never refer
to any individual person using plural
pronouns such as they using contrived
pronouns such as g or with any similar
terminology that reflects values the
student does not share
the suspension came after the student
had been engaged in a conversation on
the bus over gender with friends over
the perceived difficulty in using plural
pronouns for an individual in spanish
which uses masculine and feminine
plurals a female student overheard the
discussion allegedly told the student
there were more than two genders no
there aren't there's only two genders
the student allegedly replied
that conversation continued in
contentious text exchange which was
shown to him by school administrators in
printed form when he was suspended
so students now being suspended for the
great crime of pointing out the reality
which is that male and female are
categories that exist
meanwhile in florida according to
breitbart.com parents of a 13 year old
daughter have filed a federal lawsuit
against a florida school district after
officials at deer lake middle school
secretly transitioned her into a
transgender male or a biological girl
who says she wants to live as a boy
including her
including allowing her to use male
spaces like bathrooms and choosing
pronouns
and this of course is the scariest and
most insane thing that is happening at
our nation's public schools not just
happening in the public schools by the
way
it's happening in the medical context as
well abigail schreier reported on this
case in washington state where there was
a kid who was suicidal happened to be
autistic was put on 72-hour suicide
watch and in the process of that suicide
watch
the administrators at this facility
convinced the kid basically that he was
a member of the opposite gender and then
told the parents that unless they
started transition processes
the kid would not be released back to
them the parents took the kid moved out
of state the kid is still living as his
biological sex happily not in the state
of washington okay now we're seeing this
happen in public schools
jeffrey in january littlejohn's daughter
who is referred to as a.g in court
filings did talk about her gender
confusion with her mother who holds a
master's degree in counseling from
florida state university
january spoke at a gathering of the
florida family policy council about the
school withholding from her and her
husband what the school did without
their knowledge or permission
she said when our daughter told us she
was experienced to stress about her
gender at the height of the pandemic we
were completely caught by surprise she
had expressed no signs of gender
confusion or distress in early childhood
or leading up to this announcement so we
were trying our best to navigate these
uncharted waters and support her in the
best way we could and help her through
her feelings we found a counselor
started our own research which led us to
gender ideology
apparently according to a lawsuit filed
by the parents this is the washington
examiner now the lawsuit says the little
johns informed their daughter's math
teacher rima kelly about their
teenager's gender dysphoria and
continued treatment with a mental health
counselor kelly offered to inform the
school about their daughter's desire to
identify as non-binary the parents
declined a couple of weeks later while
she was getting into the car the little
john's daughter mentioned the school had
asked her which bathroom she wanted to
use which the lawsuit says she thought
was funny
january littlejohn told the washington
examiner that was the first time she
became aware that the school was meeting
with her daughter assisting the teenager
in embracing a different gender identity
in school settings
the school claimed the child needed to
authorize her
needed to needed to authorize for her
parents to be at the meeting
so in other words according to the
school if the kid didn't authorize the
parents the parents could not be at the
meeting so just to get this straight in
public schools you cannot give a
band-aid or an advil to a child without
parental permission but if the kid comes
in and says i'm a member of the opposite
gender the parents are not allowed to
know about it according to many of these
schools unless the kid gives permission
the little john's attorney bernadette
broyle's non-profit law firm called the
child and parental rights campaign said
the school could not provide the text
the law officials referred to
the examiner reported the lawsuit says
the school district was relying upon lcs
lesbian gay bisexual transgender gender
non-conforming and questioning support
guide which expressly directs school
administrators to avoid notifying the
child's parents about a child's gender
identity claiming such an action could
lead to the student becoming homeless in
other words the school cares more about
the kid than the parents do which is the
big lie that you're constantly told by
left-wing school public school officials
we care more about your kids than you do
yes screw you you don't you don't
i guarantee you parents care more about
their kids
on average
than school administrators do
and the belief that school
administrators have any level of
expertise navigating gender dysphoria is
insane
it's also insane that all of these
public interest groups on behalf of
radical gender ideology are the ones
writing the guides for the schools
that's totally crazy
so you have a left-wing organization
like glaad
writing the the policy prescriptions for
how to treat
kids who are gender-confused at the age
of eight
insane
and non-reflective of what parents
actually want
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video